i did meth once by accident by accident
math
by accident no wonder you have
depression it was by i thought it was
coke
my buddy was like do you want to do some
coke i'm like josh i didn't know it was
meth you snorted it though yeah it was
rough
it was it's the only time i've ever been
kicked out of a strip club
and i got kicked out because look i did
one hit
one line and i'm no quitter so i did
another one just to make sure it was bad
and it was terrible math i had this
crazy
thin layer of sweat like a slime just a
slime
and at the time i was wearing like
button-down shirts tucked into my acid
wash jeans you know with my black belt
you know what i'm saying
yeah and uh i'm out at the strip club
and i have this thin layer of sweat and
i didn't realize i got home
sweat on my shirt sweat on the underarms
and
this is how bad i looked i couldn't get
a dancer
to give me a lap dance tough i kept
going dance and they were like
pass hard pass so this woman
would go how about can we go into the
boom boom room she was like yeah
she walked me into a door i walked in
she shut the door it was the way leading
outside
the back i couldn't get back in i had to
walk back out into the parking lot
i walked up to the front ticket booth
and i said hey i was supposed to get a
dance
and she must she let me outside by
accident she goes no that was an
accident
she was like your night's over yeah your
night's over we have a giant puerto
rican i said
we have one giant puerto rican who will
dance for you
with one realty just keep getting giant
puerto ricans
we have a giant puerto rican with one
tit she says she's familiar with you
she says she knows what you like yeah oh
yeah
you like it rough yeah kicked out of the
strip club but the math was
i hated it i i can't understand any
drugs heroin is the only one where i'm
like yeah probably shouldn't ever do
that
i probably love it but that's because
the first half
of every heroine movie looks like the
most fun you'll ever have
the first half before the [ __ ] goes down
you're like oh they're having you watch
the movie blow i want all the cocaine in
the world
dude that looks like a good [ __ ] time
you know george
uh is basically trying to convert to a
female now i think
has got a titty implant what but stevie
blue eyes was
was bunk mates with george jung how but
george young's got to be
70 right now right he has a set of tits
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son